ben ali d autres façons pour les chefs
de continuer à travailler hier les
élèves du secteur de montigny-sur-aube
en côte-d'or ont eu droit à un menu
préparé par un chef étoilé à la cantine
et comme c'était la chandeleur il y
avait en entrée une crêpe une simple
crêpes plutôt une aumônière surprise
fabien acosta christophe gaillard sa
brigade n'est pas là mais les fourneaux
reprenne vie le temps d'une journée le
chef takashi kinoshita n'avait plus
ressenti cela depuis des mois ça me fait
vraiment plaisir
parfum de cuisine le ch alors et tout ça
c'est ça me manque c'est pas comme
d'habitude mais ça fait du bien ça fini
car c'est pour une tout autre clientèle
que le chef s'active aujourd'hui les
enfants de la cantine scolaire du
village ils vont découvrir un menu
étoilé aujourd'hui sachant de leurs donc
j'ai fait deux clubs de la base entré
aux molières de de salade de lentilles
et puis un petit peu de sauce et la
mi-août à autour truite au safran et
légumes de saison pour continuer puis
biscuit roulé au miel tout le dressage
des assiettes se fait ici à la cantine
des enfants sont servis comme dans un
restaurant gastronomique
l'aumônière est un peu dure à
appréhender mais le repas semblent
apprécier des liquides chalet girl et et
puis on n'a pas du papa moussa
photo df au japon même pas pourquoi
j'aime trop les antilles à mellac
rappelé barack obama
d'habitude on mange des légumes et moi
j'aime pas trop les légumes c'est bien
parce qu'ils ont très curieux quelle
sauce vous mettez qu'est le légume
s'expliquer ce que le plein de questions
et puis en même temps ils ont félicité
trois tickets en chef et où bassam
doublement plaisir
cette initiative ne devrait pas rester
une journée à part désormais le chef
étoilé viendra régulièrement à la
rencontre de ces petits gourmets me
semble essentiel que quelqu'un qui
représente la gastronomie comme takashi
éduque les enfants dès le premier âge
pour leur faire comprendre qu'il est
essentiel de travailler avec des
produits locaux et en bourgogne
quand on apprécie les grandes tablées et
la gastronomie locale cela s'entend à
tout âge